okay crazy campers make yourselves at
home this is a great place with a lot of
time activity but don't go beyond
campsite come on we just have a little
adventure who's with me there's a health
or there is abandoned
listen to the treasure [ __ ] let's go see
a story circle pie
we heard oh how are you coming
where did you get the fish it was in a
toy chunk and we can start the story and
then Webber add the fish to continue the
story once upon a time there was a girl
what can I do for you I'd like to take
it for you where to any more signs era
let's watch her extended passenger boat
you're in good man sir so go ahead and
visit Hey winning story time is over
everyone get ready for bed you hear that
uh-oh what now are we in the middle of
nowhere no no no no we passed nowhere an
hour ago
I think this is magic what just happened
we have our own story circle here and we
can finish the story well what are you
waiting for
where are we how about I know don't know
how you miss little sweet I don't
understand it's not know where did you
get that our notes one kid found it I
had a little sister I thought I lost her
maybe you do realize all of them you can
miracles happen every day my dear of
coursing it now you just have to believe
what makes you so sure that this year
will be different you just have to do
what you see
[Music]
you